[Música]
i
essa performance chamas o buraco
essa performance inspirada dos nomes da
vagina deve analisar
ela foi criada num dia em que eu e duas
amigas atrizes
devemos trabalhar os nomes da vagina e
eu olhei para o texto isso texto tem
muita fala tem muita expressão
será que a mulher se expressa será que a
mulher fala eu quero trabalhar o mesmo
texto
mas de uma forma contrária com silêncio
como a voz que não é ouvida neste
momento como esse é criar esta
performance eu sou terapeuta holístico
no meu procuro contrapé alta atende
muitas mulhers e nessa atender muitas
mulheres
ouvi muitas histórias aprendi mais
silenciar escutar histórias a
desenvolver empatia
eu sou gay de steffi nada assumir
assumir a minha própria verdade eq
cinema
será que as mulheres assumem ser mulher
e ainda neste processo fazendo ainda
outros laços com a minha história ea
história dessas mulheres
uma das coisas que eu descobri como
terapeuta os psicólogos vão achar uma
pessoa mais louca
vocês sabiam que a depressão pós parto
ela não existe
não existem escritas não existe
depressão pós parto
o que acontece é que a depressão pós
parto é só uma fuga uma fuga de pessoas
acumuladas ao longo da vida
nós temos pessoas na infância
temos o professor na adolescência e
quando começamos a entrar para a
juventude e para quem já tem filhos sabe
muito bem disso
quando a gente dá um parto ao momento em
que nos dá um vazio
e é nesse momento que nos dá esse vazio
que essa depressão estas de persons
acumuladas ao longo da vida vem a dona e
alguns chamam de depressão pós parto
mas é incrível como algumas mulheres são
impedidas sentirá do pré sal até
depressão pós parto e que diz a elas que
mimo
são coisas do vosso tempo que é são
outras mulheres
quero partilhar outro fato vez
convidaram para ir dar um workshop sobre
amor próprio
mas eu ia para um grupo muito diferente
dos grupos onde estou habituado a
facilitar e abra um grupo de mulheres
que ia fazer uma aula de sexualidade
as famosas aulas que vocês já ouviram
falar com certeza essas têm suazo o doca
e outras coisas muito sexuais que todos
vocês sabem eu saí da casa
já entre gado porque essas mulheres vão
fazer nestes custos porque elas estão lá
seguir à aula
encontrei uma média de 20 mulheres olhei
pra elas e as ankle calei tenha uma
dúvida não é procon de idéias que vocês
vieram cá fazer porque estão aqui
e naquele momento apercebendo um ligeiro
silêncio
elas tinham que fazer uma introspecção
questionar porque estava ali naquele
momento eu fui percebendo com muitas
delas estavam naquele espaço são simples
e menta para salvar casamentos obra com
uma amiga diz que ela não era boa de
cama porque ela não era uma boa mulher
porque ela não sabia cozinhar que não
tinha jeito
mas será que todas as mulheres têm que
ser assim
será que há uma forma de ser uma mulher
ideal perfeita porque estamos
constantemente a rotulá los
quero partilhar um outro fato há uns
anos eu li o livro nikiti paulinense a
acho que muitos conhecem é um erro mas
de poligamia pra mim hoje nikiti é um
livro do autoconhecimento a duas frases
que dizem muito que vem de uma tribo
muito famosa que são as ruas que nós
temos a idéia de que elas são super
incluídas por sexualmente são boas do
carro mas elas têm muito mais do que
isso então vou pegar nessas frases e vou
partilhar vos a primeira homem só é teu
quando está dentro de ti é minhas
queridas só pode ser eu o teu corpo é
teu aquilo que está contigo o teu corpo
o único momento é isso que todos vocês
imaginaram a outra frase que messi
também muito comigo que diz muito sobre
a atualidade do uso
vocês também podem levar no sentido
sexual mas ele vai também além disso ela
diz
de que adianta usar o mundo afora
se nunca viajaram para dentro de si
mesmo podemos levar procedido sexual mas
vai muito além disso quando as viagens
externas nós fazemos quando os vi asas
nós proporcionamos porque estamos em
conflito porque estávamos seus problemas
e não fazemos a viagem interna
dom nesse processo eu fui aprendendo a
desenvolver empatia
quero ver e partilhar como viram na
performance ela tem a voz já não tinha
tenha tenha sentimentos eu não tinha
abriu a boca não
quem dá espaço para abrir a boca ninguém
ela está inserida a onde uma sociedade
geralmente somos nós a sociedade
fazemos com os outros se calem então
queremos proporcionar começar a ouvir o
vosso corpo o corpo ele sempre sábado
antes de ou enfrentar com uma amiga
tomar um café está cheio de dúvidas
meu corpo já me disse que tem que ser
feito geralmente se eu já tinha por
exemplo com o meu parceiro e não falei
com ele que uma conta dessa primeira
mesmo que eu vá tomar um café
tenho um nó na garganta então meu corpo
não disse que eu preciso falar eu tenho
sentimento nem que eu se instala
dói no peito então o corpo não disse que
tem ser feito vamos fazer viagens entre
outros
vamos dar voz ao nosso silêncio é esta a
minha proposta e muito grave